[موسيقى]
يعقد المستشار الالماني ولافشلت اجتماعا
اليوم عبر تقنيه الفيديو مع قاده مجموعه
الدول الصناعيه سبع ويبحث الزعامه امكانيه
فرض عقوبه اكثر صرامه على روسيا وتقديم
المزيد من المساعده لاوكرانيا هذا وافاد
المتحدث باسم الحكومه الالمانيه بان
الرئيس الاوكرانيه بدو ميرزالسكي سيشاركه
في الاجتماع عبر تقنيه الفيديو وكان ذلك
قد تاكد في خطاب مصور الاحد انه نسق
المواقف في مكالمه هاتفيه مع الرئيس
الامريكي قبل اجتماع الدول السبعه
هذا وافد الترياسه الاوكرانيه بان الرئيس
اقترح خلال اتصال هاتفيه مع الرئيس
الامريكي تنظيم قمه سلام عالميه وكان رئيس
الاوكراني قد قال انه شكر نظيره الامريكيه
على ما وصفها بالمساعده الدفاعيه والماليه
غير المسبقه التي تقدمها بلاده لاوكرانيا
والتي قال لا تساهم في نجاحها في ساحه
المعركه وتدعم استقرار اقتصادها وشدد
زنسكي على اهميه تشكيل الدفاع الجوي
الاوكراني قادر على حمايه المدنيين
والبنيه التحتيه للبلاد خصوصا في الوقت
الحالي مع دخولي فصل الشتاء
وفي بروكسل يبحث وزراء وخليجيه الاتحاد
الاوروبي ملف الحربي في اوكرانيا
والتجهيزه لعقوبه جديده بالاضافه الى
مراجعه العقوبه السابقه
الخارجيه والامن في الاتحاد
على روسيا لم تنتهي بعد مشيرا الى ان
الوزراء الاوروبيين سيتفقون ايضا على فرض
حزمه عقوبات مشدده على ايران
الخلافه ما زال قائما بين الدول الاعضاء
في الاتحاد بشان تفاصيل الحزمه التاسعه من
العقوبات على روسيا
العقوبات تجاه روسيا والحزمه التاسعه
مازلنا لم نحسم الامر بشانهما معرض حتى
الان هو مجرد اقتراحات وهو ما نقوم به في
المفوضيه والمجلس والوزراء هم يحسمون
القرار ضمننا هذا الصباح ان نتلقينا الضوء
الاخضر لكن ما زالت هناك خلافات بين الدول
ربما يقرا جديدا اليوم او غدا حتى الان كل
ما نوقش له مجرد عرض وطرحه ولا قرار حاسما
حتى الان
البريطانيه مركز سماها الجاذبيه السياسيه
في العالم يتجه نحو الجنوبي والشرق واضاف
وزير الخارجيه البريطاني في مؤتمر صحفيا
الرئيس
لما وصفه لتدمير القوانين التي تحمي الدول
انه شن حرب تناقض قيم النظام الدولي
ضروره كسبي دعم المزيد من الدول
والعلاقات الذات المنفعه المتبادله
معنا من امام ديوانا المستشاريه الالمانيه
في برلين مراسل الجزيره عيسى طيبي ومن كيف
مراسل الجزيره عامر لاف يبدا معك عيسى
طيبي والمتوقع من هذا الاجتماع لمجموعه
السبع خاصه في ظل هذا التباين في المواقف
في عده مستويات فيما يتعلق بالحرب الروسيه
على اوكرانيا العقوبات الغاز وتفاصيل
كثيره
اعلن في المؤتمر الصحفي عندما سئل عن
مساله امداد اوكرانيه بس هل سيتم بحث هذا
العمل في مجموعه السبع اليوم قال لن يتم
التطرق الى مساله دفع وتزويد القران قمه
مجموعات السابع لهذا اليوم قال بان مساله
امداد اوكرانيا بالاسلحه تقع ضمن صيغتي
رانشتاين والتي يتم التنسيق فيها بين
وزيره الدفاع الالمانيه وشركائها الغربي
جديد بان قمه اليوم قمه مجموعه السبع لن
تبحث امداده بالاسلحه لان الحديث منذ
الصباح كان يتمحور حول امداد نوعيه
للاسلحه هكذا كان الحديث لكن المتحدث باسم
المستشار وباسم الحكومه هكذا غير ذلك
النقطه الاخرى وهي موضوع شرق وجنوب
اوكرانيا ما يجري كما تقول مصادر متعدده
في برلين اليوم بانه ايضا مدعات لان يطرح
في اجتماع اليوم خصوصا مساله الدعم السريع
لاوكرانيا في مساله الطاقه لان روسيا باتت
جهيمن على مساله تدمير البنيه التحتيه
للطاقه في اوكرانيا لذلك سيبحث الزعماء
هذه النقطه الامر الاخر ويمثله العقوبات
على روسيا هناك مصادر تتحدث بان مجموعه
السبعه اليوم ستقوم بعمليه استقراء ومراجع
للعقوبات السابقه وايضا تصعيد ما يمكن
جعله ضمن العقوبات القصوى ضد روسيا النقطه
الاخرى التي يجب الاشاره اليها وهي التي
وهي مثلا
مفاوضات السلام
الغربيون الان في هذه القمه يريدون الضغط
على روسيا ولكن لا يريدون الخروج من خيار
المفاوضات هناك حديث بان البحث الان على
الصيغه معينه لدفع روسيا للجلوس طاوله
المفاوضات هناك ايضا مقترحوكراني كما ادى
به مكتب الرئيس
وجود مؤتمر دولي للسلام شولت اكد ذلك ايضا
في وقت سابق خلال محادثه الاخيره التي
امتدت لمده ساعه مع الرئيس الروسي وهناك
حديث ايضا بان شركان لا يريدون ان يحشروا
الرئيس الروسي في الزاويه بمعنى اخر
الخيار الذي يريده الغربيون الان ليس فقط
هو الخيار العسكري المواجهه المباشره وهذا
ايضا ما دعت اليه وشنطه في وقت سابق لذلك
يريد المستشار الذي طبعا الى هذا الاجتماع
الذي يسبق قمه اخرى غدا في باريس ان تكون
هذه القمه قمه مجموعه السبع لدعم اوكرانيا
لدعم مباشر الاوكراني لكن لا يبدو ان يكون
الدعم المسيح نعم
لا في هناك دعوه الان من الرئيس زينسكي
لقمه سلام عالمي»
وما ترشده زنسكي من هاب ايضا نذكر بابرز
المواقف الصادره في الساعه ال24 الماضيه
من اوكرانيا
نعم مياده ربما يعني وفقا لكثير من
المراقبين هنا اذا اردنا ان نعطي الكلمه
المفتاح للرد على سؤالك هي الضمانات بمعنى
ان الاوكرانيين هنا يخشون من ان يتركوا
للجلوس مع روسيا وبالتالي هم يريدون
ضمانات دوليه لانه لا يوجد ثقه وجود او
عقد مثل هذا المؤتمر الدولي سيمنح اوكرانه
وهكذا يعتقد الاوكرانيين بان هذا المؤتمر
سيمنحهم هذه الضمانات لانهم في القناعه
الاوكرانيه حاليا مياده هم يعتبرون انها
سواء عندما تتحدث روسيا عن السلام وعن
استعدادها للجلوس الى طاوله المفاوضات فما
فما هذا الا محاوله لكسب الوقت هم يقولون
بان الخسائر الكبيره التي تكبدها الجيش
الروسي لا تسمح له بمواصله القتال
بالكفاءه التي بداتها وبالتالي هو يريد
كسب الوقت لاعاده تنظيم صفوف وهو ما لا
تريده اوكرانيا في هذه المرحله بالتاليه
تريد ضمانات لكي نصل الى نهايه الحرب
وتحصل هي على حقوقها اذا لا وجود للثقه
المتبادله بين الطرفين هذا طبعا يظهر في
كثير من التصريحات الاوكرانيه التي تتحدث
دائما عن ان الرئيس بوتين يتحدث بشكل
عالمي انه سيستمر في قتل الاوكرانيين
والسيطره على بلادهم ومن خلالها هذه
الامور سيقوم بالضغط على اوكرانيا وعلى
المجتمع الدولي لتحقيق مطالبه ربما اكثر
ما قد يشير الى انعدام هذه الثقه تصريحات
مستشار مكتب الرئيس بالامس ميخائيل همم
دوليات الذي قال بان ال- ال- ربما الشكل
الوحيد الذي يمكن من خلاله انهاء هذه
الحرب هو ان تهزم روسيا في الميدان على
الارض وان تعزل اقتصاديا وان تبعد عن
الاسواق العالميه بل وان يدعم عمليات
للتخريب في داخل اوكرانيا ربما هذا الكلام
مبالغ به لكن تبقى هذه وجهه النظر
الاوكرانيه لايقاف هذه الحرب وطبعا الذي
دفعه الرئيس همم
لهذه الدعوه للم العالمي هو ما يعتبره
كثير هنا الردود الايجابيه على الصيغه
الاوكرانيه لتحقيق السلام والمقصود هنا
طبعا النقاب ال 10 التي تحدث عنها الذي
اعلن عنها بدايه في مؤتمر قمه العشرين
الشهر الماضي يا رئيس اليونسكي
شكرا جزيلا لك شكرا موصول لك من امام
ديوان المستشارين الالمانيه في برلين
مراسل الجزيره عصبي